>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE BEGIN WITH NEWS JUST BREAKING
RIGHT NOW AT THIS MINUTE, AND WE
START WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT.
ACCORDING TO A BREAKING NEW
REPORT FROM POLITICO, THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT HAS IN FACT VOTED
TO OVERTURN ROE VS. WADE.
IF THIS REPORT TURNS OUT TO BE
TRUE, ABORTION WILL NOT BE
REGULATED AT THE STATE LEVEL,
MEANING IT IS NOT GOING TO BE
ILLEGAL PROBABLY IN MOST STATES
IN THE UNITED STATES, THERE WILL
BE VARIED RESTRICTIONS.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES
INVOLVING THIS CASE HAS TO DO
WITH WHETHER OR NOT
ROE V. WADE -- AND THIS IS WHAT
CONSERVATIVES HAVE OFTEN
BELIEVED -- CONSTITUTIONALISTS
HAVE BELIEVED, ORIGINALISTS HAVE
BELIEVED, IS THAT IT ENUMERATED
A RIGHT THAT DID NOT EXIST
WITHIN THE CONSTITUTION.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THIS IS
THE DRAFT OPINION, UNFLINCHING
REPUDIATION OF THE '73 DECISION
GUARANTEEING A FEDERAL
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTION ON
ABORTION RIGHTS AS THEY REPORT
IN POLITICO.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD VERSUS CASEY
THAT LARGELY MAINTAIN THAT
RIGHT.
IF THIS REPORT IS TRUE,
JUSTICE ALITO WRITES IT WAS
EGREGIOUSLY WRONG FROM THE START
AND WE HOLD THAT THEY MUST BE
OVERRULED.
HE WRITES IN THE DOCKET LABELED
"OPINION OF THE COURT."
IT IS TIME TO HEED THE
CONSTITUTION, RETURN THE ISSUE
OF ABORTION TO THE PEOPLES
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES.
THAT'S WHERE THE ISSUE OF
JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY COMES INTO
PLAY.
DO YOU ENUMERATE A RIGHT NOT
SPECIFICALLY SPELLED OUT IN THE
CONSTITUTION, OR SHOULD IT BE UP
TO THE STATES, WHICH IS WHAT
CONSERVATIVES ALWAYS ARGUED.
DELIBERATIONS ON CONTROVERSIAL
CASES HAVE IN THE PAST BEEN
FLUID, JUSTICES CANNOT SOMETIMES
DO CHANGE THEIR VOTES AND
OPINIONS AS OPINIONS ARE
CIRCULATED AMONG THE DIFFERENT
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
MAJOR DECISIONS CAN BE SUBJECT
TO MULTIPLE DRAFTS, SOMETIMES
UNTIL JUST DAYS BEFORE THE
DECISION IS UNVEILED.
BUT THE REAL HEART OF HIS WORDS,
IF, IN FACT, THIS REMAINS THE
FINAL DECISION, WOULD BE IT WAS
EGREGIOUSLY WRONG FROM THE
START, IT'S REASONING WAS
EXCEPTIONALLY WEAK, AND THE
DECISION HAS HAD DAMAGING
CONSEQUENCES AND FAR FROM
BRINGING ABOUT A NATIONAL
SETTLEMENT OF THE ABORTION
ISSUE, ROE AND CASEY HAVE
INFLAMED DEBATE AND DEEPENED
DIVISION IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF WE LOOK AT WHAT THEY ARE
REPORTING, A PERSON FAMILIAR
WITH THE DELIBERATIONS,
ACCORDING TO POLITICO SAID THAT
FOUR OTHER REPUBLICAN APPOINTED
JUSTICES, CLARENCE THOMAS,
NEIL GORSUCH, BRETT KAVANAUGH,
AMY CONEY BARRETT VOTED WITH HIM
IN THE CONFERENCE AND HELD AMONG
THE JUSTICES AFTER HEARING OR
GOAL, ORAL ARGUMENT, THIS IS
BACK IN DECEMBER.
WE DON'T EXPECT THE FINAL
DECISION UNTIL SOMETIME IN JUNE,
MAYBE JULY EVEN.
USUALLY IN MAY OR JUNE I'M A BUT
THE THREE JUSTICES ARE WORKING
ON ONE OR MORE DISSENTS THAT
WOULD BE PART OF ANY FINAL
DECISION THAT COMES OUT.
BUT IT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING
TO WATCH.
THIS WILL ABSOLUTELY BE
DEMAGOGUED BY THE LEFT IN THE
COUNTRY.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE
DOCUMENT LABELED AS A FIRST
DRAFT OF THE MAJORITY OPINION,
IT WOULD INDICATE THEY MAY BE
LEANING AS OF TONIGHT TO
OVERRULE ROE V. WADE.
THAT IS CONSIDERED PRECEDENT.
THE INESCAPABLE CONCLUSION IS
THE RIGHT TO AN ABORTION IS NOT
DEEPLY ROOTED IN THE NATION'S
HISTORY OR TRADITIONS.
THE CONSTITUTION DOES NOT
PROHIBIT THE CITIZENS OF EACH
STATE FROM REGULATING OR
PROHIBITING ABORTION.
THE DRAFT CONCLUDES.
IN OTHER WORDS, ABORTION WILL
NOT BE MADE ILLEGAL BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, IT WILL BE
UP TO THE STATES TO DECIDE.
ROE AND CASEY AGGREGATED THAT
THAT AUTHORITY.
WE NOW OVERRULE THESE DECISIONS
AND RETURN THAT AUTHORITY TO THE
PEOPLE AND THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVE.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE ON THIS
BREAKING NEWS STRAIGHT AHEAD
TONIGHT.
BUT THIS IS PRETTY INTERESTING.
JUST TO BE VERY CLEAR HERE, EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS A DRAFT, SOUNDS
LIKE T